hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse RN calm and in this video I want
to bring you a quick tutorial on how to
place
AED pads on an adult patient or a child
8 years or older I'm going to show you
the landmarks and show you how to do it
and mr. Jones right here is going to be
my mannequin to help us out with that
now after you watch this video be sure
to watch my other video on how to
actually use an AED on a patient I
demonstrate how to turn it on how to
plug it in what you do if a patient has
a hairy chest everything like that and I
cover that and the link should be
popping up so you can watch that video
so let's get started okay so your IEG is
arrived and you're going to put on your
ne D pads I'm going to show you quickly
how to do that what you'll want to do is
you'll of course want to look at the
chef's make sure it's not hairy make
sure they don't have an implanted device
make sure there's not it's not covered
in water or they have any medication
patches and if they do you want to take
care of that the very first one will go
on the upper right part of the chest
right below the collarbone and you'll
take that pad luckily the pads tell you
where to go but it's never hurts to
practice and you're going to press it
down firmly you want it to have a really
good connection next you are going to
take your other pad and you're going to
put it left of the nipple with the top
edge of the pad just a few inches below
the armpit so it's going to go right
here
and we're just going to take that at the
edge right couple inches below the
armpit and then we're just want to push
it down really good nice and sticky and
he is ready to be shocked so that is
placement for AV pads on an adult in a
child 8 years or older